the reason I talk about henry david
thoreau in the book who seems to be
really an unlikely digital philosopher
because he his reputation is that he ran
away from civilization and ran away from
technology when he built his cabin at
Walden Pond and he's in the stereotype
he's the great escape artist but in fact
Thoreau was not escaping civilization at
Walden and the reason I use him is that
he built that cabin as an experiment in
striking a balance not in disconnecting
but in putting himself just a short
distance from civilization and going
back and forth a lot to see if he could
make that work he was a very short walk
from the village of Concord mass where
he spent most of his life he was back
and forth all the time he entertained as
many as 30 people in that little cabin
at one time during the two years that he
wrote the famous Walden so he was in
many ways like us you know trying to
wrestle with in his time the new
connectedness which was the telegraph
the railroad all these devices that were
making life busier and more hectic and
his basic message that I think is so
valuable today is that we all need to
set up these zones where we're
relatively less connected where we can
go back inward and sort of take all that
outward richness that we're pulling in
and doing something do something with it
do something fresh and creative with it
he has a wonderful quote where he says
another issue in his time and throws
time was Believe It or Not addiction to
the post office to checking your mail
too often and he says the row writes at
one point in proportion as a man's
inward life fails he goes back more
desperately and constantly to the post
office and he said yeah as you can be
sure that the man who walks away with
the greatest number of letters has not
heard from himself in a long time
it's a wonderful sort of diagnosis of
what we're facing today the more
addicted you are to that outward Colet
kind of connected life the less you're
getting out of it inwardly and it's just
a matter of spending a healthier balance
so that's one of the reasons I used
Thoreau as a sort of wonderful example
of finding those zones where we can
strike a better balance for ourselves